[Music]
League of Legends and nerfing Opie
champions name a more iconic duo Elway
balance has always been something that
ride has struggled with but who can
blame them League of Legends is a game
with so many moving parts that it's
nearly impossible to balance perfectly
which is why today we wanted to take a
look at the times when riot really
messed up the times when a champion was
so overpowered and they weren't just
nerfed they were annihilated the times
were riot and gutted a champion so hard
they basically took them out of the game
here are the top 10 champions in a
league of legends history kicking off
our list is one of League of Legends
most reworked champions mordekaiser
heading into the 2015 World Championship
Ryan decided to shake things up for
league's biggest tournament by making
several champions including mordekaiser
insanely Opie the juggernauts we think
are guys that are like really slow
moving really tanky do crazy damage if
you get near them or if they get near
you somehow alongside has crazy damage
and insane defense this new mordekaiser
gained extra XP on every minion kill if
an ally was in the lane with him meaning
he almost always had the level lead on
his opponent meanwhile his support was
gaining levels normally so more
dominated any bot lane he was in and
then there was his dragon ghost yeah
the dragon now could be in trouble
go back that
did they control the dragon but they get
two kills afterwards the seed potential
of this dragon even against a full team
is strong now they have a full dragon a
level mind and a four-man push mid
throughout world's 2015 more two had a
nearly 100% pick or ban rate he only saw
the rift four times that entire
tournament but when he did we got plays
like this big and can sing knocks up
three and the dragon is still chasing
the end of the ad carry Lord's got to be
careful kill the dragon value is big on
this one all is well
there's a triple kill they're going no
the good news is right nerfed him a few
times after worlds and eventually took
away that ridiculous XP thing leaving
the one's unstoppable Titan of Forgotten
flavor of the month until a recent
rework over buffed him again coming in
at number 9 is Olaf back in season 2
this Berserker was an extremely
snowballing champion who went in the
proper hand was capable of winning any
fight I talking about it with saint's
earlier he's like I love playing all off
and so look you lay and just throw it
back and forth then you can go you see a
little aggression around a boy boy but
he is going to go strong on this I think
is gonna try no go for the kill actually
I thought he was gonna try now what is
going on shows just did not know this
was gonna happen
a cleaned-up double kill for a boy boy
but in past 3.0 100 ops qw and our
abilities were nerfed he lost a ton of
damage had weaker crowd control and even
his cooldown for longer they took out
everything strong about the character
and somehow off mains just had to
uninstall the game and switch over to
dota 2
ooofff got it so bad that the community
coined the term whopping or the Olaf
treatment for whatever ride over nerves
a champion to the point of a uselessness
we're going all the way back to season
one for our number eight entry back
then Evelyn was a champion that wreaked
havoc on solo kiss
which meant that riot took it upon
themselves to gut this champion into a
Bolivian they neutered her attack speed
sustain and most importantly removed her
stunts these changes made Evelyn the
weakest champion in the game for an
entire year prompting a rework and these
changes were so bad that people began
reporting Evelyn players because picking
her was considered cool II think
Evelyn's been playable since but she's
never reached the highs of season one
again but this is this is perfect
getting opportunity oh yeah they took
out her stunned she's gone
let's keep living in the good old days
for our number seven entry with Diana
back when she was released in 2012 she
quickly dominated the meta but then Ryan
destroyed her kit early on in season two
every ability was gutted in terms of
damage hit boxes and range
Diana's win rate dropped by 12% one of
the biggest drops any champion has ever
seen she went from a powerful menacing
assassin to one of the weakest champions
in the game according to some riders
Diana along with OAuth and Evelyn are
some of the biggest nerfs they've ever
done coming in at number six is McCauley
her rework in 2018 made her one of the
most oppressive on interactive champions
league of legends has ever seen she
became a flashy and honestly overpowered
assassin capable of doing things no
normal champion should ever feel out to
do
yeah they managed to get this inhibitor
turret most likely as well as this siege
minion is going to be down to beat has a
lot of sneakiness diving on forward and
Bonner didn't last a couple of seconds
he's going one before lava is gonna be
the first one going down
he's going to be tagged up but no back
flip going to be reactivated in show me
the tube but nothing one before
and thus right began there a long
attempt to balance a collie some nerves
were relatively small but over time they
got bigger a collie Mane's started
sweating when she lost healing on her
cue or when her W no longer kept her
safe from turrets riots tried everything
even removing the micro stun from her
arm but after each wave of nerfs she
stayed on top of high e low tearless and
pro play riot recently went in for
another round of nerfs which caused the
collie mains to complain but then they
went in for a quick hot fix buff to keep
a collie from being well completely
irrelevant piercing and rending her way
into the number 5 spot on our list is
Calista in season 5 Calista was one of
if not the most dominant champion in the
game she boasted a 70% pick and ban rate
across all major regions in pro play
with an insane 58% win rate they want
the turret they're gonna burn the
Karthus all to get it and they will get
it wolf comes in takes a lot of damage
he's gonna pop his up just in time as SK
Telecom chasing down the damage from
Bing is insane right now double kill
can he get more triple kill the problem
was simple her ability to hop between
auto attacks gave her crazy range thanks
for passive and it also let her abuse
attack speed items like no other
champion after a few patches we saw big
nerfs her backwards - was reined in they
slashed her attack speed and her damage
the list went on and on
yet Calista was still seeing play with
some success looper is actually gonna
have to back off but can they flank
again
shut down my stick say I don't know how
this one's gonna turn out and that's it
stay he's going low but he comes back
but riot put the final nail in Callistus
coffin in patch 6.6 when they
obliterated her attack speed and tied
her passive to the presence of her
support
she's languished outside of the meta
ever since these days she has a tiny 1.0
pic rate in soloqueue
making his way into our list at number 4
is H rocks originally underwhelming and
often neglected by riot after his
release he received a mini rework in
2017 after four straight years of
community complaints and then for some
reason right decided to rework him again
the next year but what really broke him
was a hotfix right after the second
rework they introduced a new champion
with mechanics different than his old
ones and then it takes people a little
while to pick him up now he's obviously
just broken because they hotfix buffed
him really in a situation where they did
not need to do but nobody asked for or
wanted this rework but it basically
turned eight rocks into a brand new
champion one that could win almost every
1v1 in a solo Lane
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
try and do the full combo in a press R
and then drop all my damage on there and
it's really simple so you kind of press
R and then from there you kind of just
mash your face on the keyboard and you
just kind of do that for a little bit
and there you go that is how you play
aatrox in pro play this of course
resulted in him being abused by pros
blunder trying to make something happen
but G to look like they just let this
engage this one now they've already got
to pick onto the enemy jungler
damage and the shy but he trucks his
dominance called for a lot of nerfs and
changes but the most powerful thing
about aatrox was also a core part of his
kit since day one he's revived turns out
a big scary brawler who can come back to
life after dying is pretty strong and
eventually where I removed that too
aatrox was so thoroughly picked apart my
nerves and reworks that there's nothing
of the original champion of left these
days aatrox mains just call him Boris
since if he's a new champ he may as well
have a new name too our number three
entry needs no introduction before his
nerfs kassadin sported a ridiculous 95
percent ban right we see the grass and
we see the Kassadin it's more Kassadin
ban way by the red team counted him
taken out casting Gragas we're always
seeing him and him and him down there
because when he got picked things like
oh and Alex gets he gets the false balls
maybe puts the devil peck acres around
here that's what I said with sorry
Knight take it very light that trap oh
girl it's a p1 singer for pulse Quadra
kill comes up thank you so no could we
see the Penta kill coming up Meritage
he's gonna pursue this one Terry comes
around no because Becky comes around and
guess just sails away the Penta kill it
doesn't matter because it's an ace for
gambit gaming and they're gonna go for
the baron the voidwalker hadn't seen
damage on his cue and his eat along with
low mana costs and then there was his
rift walk which traveled a crazy
distance and did an even crazier amount
of damage people started calling him
Castle win because actually getting to
play as him meant a guaranteed victory
he's gonna kick boydle back with yeah
comes modern imp in the background you
see time aprox owning the mouth this is
basically 1 V 2 that is home god alex is
coming in he's picked up two quick kills
is Donnie and Daniel
sitting on the sidelines yeah comes
darien though he gets a knock up he
secures the third kill of the fight for
gambit all they've cost was a void 'l
now we see Alex with the rift okay it's
gonna eat a gold card but daddy's been
silenced and Darien and Alex should be
able to close this one out and actually
get the kill credit thanks to the damage
he's putting down and are we gonna make
it to the tower and that's
four-for-one convincing teamfight win
for gambit and still 100% killed
participation for Alex's Kassadin then
came a wave of nurse starting in season
4 where we finally saw his reign of
terror and Brian took the silence off
his cue and took his arse man a refund
away for good measure the general
consensus on the changes well yeah he
sucked he was terrible for some this was
sad from the best champion in the game
now to one of the worst these days
Kassadin seems pretty balanced but we'll
never forget 2014 when he went from the
best champion in the game to one that
wasn't even worth it Fanning taking our
runner-up spot is rise the champion that
red just can't seem to balance from
terrorizing the game in 2013 oh [ __ ] -
machine gun rise in 2015 very close to
take it on hunter pushed him up against
the wall there's the Saracen brace along
with the arcane mastery coming out home
by Shawn wasps he goes down to answer
and that means piglet has to run for his
life the desperate powers Audie locks
him up he comes up with a double kill to
his rework in 2016 and they've gotten
the dragon just as TSM got the Baron
before it's kind of one for the other
and they have to get they're gonna end
the game here so quickly they're gonna
try to actually stop a hot Sui gonna try
to stop the backs and chase them down
they have to walk all the way up here
he's gonna find golden clue they are
playing stop the back game now on to the
Nexus turrets brown dwarf has been the
key
stop it 21 to 16 TSM picks update one
over T Ryan seems to be riots permanent
balance nightmare
he's either Opie useless or being
reworked rises various iterations have
mostly all been able to split clear
waves and kite making him eight terror
when his numbers are good but as
effectiveness in Pro play compared to
solo queue has often been a headache too
I'm gonna tell you man I don't like Ryze
guys I don't like Ryan yeah we should be
I just don't like nobody I don't want to
deal with Rhys at all I mean this [ __ ]
did you throw fireballs this is like
[ __ ] Street Fighter
when Rhys was reworked again in season 9
Rhys fans complained that he just didn't
feel like Ryze anymore with simpler
combos and less opportunity for
creativity he just lacked that essential
Rhys Ness and it didn't help that he was
super squishy without his shield when I
see my guys my shields I've missed my
shields i won the shield's back the main
problem was that Rhys mains found that
riot had made their beloved champion way
too simple but hey if you're a Ryze main
and you're not happy right now
don't worry we're sure that right will
rework him again soon there is no one
more deserving of the number one spot on
our list than the queen of nerfs herself
irelia during the early years of League
Ohio just couldn't stop nerfing her
eventually it turned into a meme a
completely different champ was too
strong better nerf irelia some item was
broken better nerf irelia the game seems
perfectly balanced and nothing is wrong
let's never alia just for safety the
first version of irelia was a
consistently strong pick despite
Wright's best attempts to nerf err
thanks to her ability to win trades
split and carry the game helped players
like faker even took her mid from behind
bengi re-entering the fight even low
health faker running from smeb smeb
doesn't know which direction to go keeps
turning around they eventually get the
kill on the wolf though and prey turned
around oh it gets a kill on two well
bang actually gets a kill the prey faker
OH
double kill getting those resets and
that is what SKT needed but a series of
nurse that began in 2015 eventually to
her out of pro play entirely even on so
acute she was rarely played from 2016
until her rework in 2018 but the new
irelia was stronger than she'd ever been
calling for a hotfix the day after her
release she became one of the strongest
duelists in the game with CC the ability
to chase down almost any champion and
Alta disarmed and of course she could
single-handedly carry any good irelia
could basically always outplay always
get the kill and always win the game and
although riot eventually went right back
to nerfing her she remains playable and
top and MIT these days
irelia is a far cry from the oppressive
nightmare that dominated high-level
league for over a year but a great
player can still make you ask riot for
some more nerfs
he knows you because it's down towards
bot Volos you ain't gonna land in the
mid lane the shock wave doesn't do too
much so that's our list but there is one
more nerf I want to talk about one
unbelievable nerf that a certain
champion barely bounce back from a nerve
so harsh that it took right two years to
undo it
graves cigar is our honorable mention
and we can only pray that riot doesn't
take it away from us again thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]